et si avec ça votre enfant rechigne
toujours à étudier l'histoire de France
et ses châteaux bien je vous propose une
autre ruse le château de Cheverny dans
le Loir-et-Cher qui raconte l'histoire
d'un héros de bande dessinée et si je
vous dis Moulinsart vous aurez bien sûr
deviné qu'il s'agit de Tintin reportage
Frédéric bonnet et Daniel Lévy
comme s'il l'imagination de millions de
lecteurs à travers le monde ne suffisait
pas comme
s'il se contentait d'être un reporter
imaginaire il faut encore qu'on nous
raconte des histoires cette histoire de
Tintin à Cheverny s'est complètement
inventé vous croyez je m'en suis pas sûr
pour que le rêve bascule dans la réalité
il faut des preuves alors la direction
de Cheverny a épluché l'oeuvre d'Hergé
le capitaine Haddock aurait-il trébuché
dans l'escalier de Cheverny le mystère
est entier mais la vraie question est de
savoir si Hergé lui-même est venu ici
Tintin aurait donc réellement vécu dans
ses murs
ah non j'y crois pas pourquoi je sais
pas j'ai mis un doute existentiel ça
serait pas la maison de Tintin ici
parce que je pense que Tata n'existe pas
des millions de francs ont pourtant été
investis à côté du château pour nous
faire croire à cette histoire
pour une exposition dont le but n'est
pas mercantile non c'est pas une
opération marketing non non je m'inscris
en faux comme on dit c'est pas du tout
c'est une c'est une opération
patrimoniale artistique culturel et si
ça doit améliorer la rentabilité du
domaine bien entendu c'est une bonne
chose
viens vite on va commencer en perçant
les secrets de la Licorne Tintin ne
savait peut-être pas que son habitation
avait été édifiée par Louis XII et
qu'elle l'attirerait un jour 350 000
visiteurs par an
en réalité que ce vernis soit Moulinsart
ou inversement ce n'est pas très
important l'essentiel est de continuer à
croire que le rêve peut un jour devenir
réalité
une exposition permanente au château de
Cheverny dans le Loir-et-Cher